- Welcome all.
My name is JJ Sharma.
I'm the TBM and FinOps Practice Lead
for KPMG Australia.
With us today is Andrew Midgley,
principal product marketing manager
for IBM Cloudability.
- Thanks, JJ.
So one thing I can tell you is
that certainly my manager has
never given me half a million dollars
to go on training,
that's for sure.
But yeah, it's awesome to be
back at re:Invent.
Over 10 years, for me,
working on Cloudability,
it's been an amazing ride.
What I would say is that this AI wave
that we're going through right now,
for me, personally,
has been very invigorating.
To me, it feels quite momentous,
very similar to the way it felt
in the early days of public cloud.
So moving forward,
it's very exciting working
with our customers
with just how transformational
this technology is.
So, yeah, it's great to be
with you today.
So let's just quickly start
with the scale of what's happening
right now in AI.
Gartner is predicting
that global spending
on Generative AI will hit $664 billion
this year.
That's up more than 75% from 2024.
It's massive growth.
Pretty much every company is investing
in AI somewhere right now.
But here's the reality check.
Less than 30% of AI leaders say
that their CEOs are happy
with the return they're getting
on that spending.
So there's a bit of a problem here.
So while everyone's racing
to build and deploy AI,
most organizations are still figuring out
how to make it financially worthwhile.
And that's really what
this session is about;
bringing some financial discipline to AI
so that all the innovation
that we're investing in
actually delivers on its goals.
So my goal for you today is
that you can leave this session
with a clear view of
the key trends shaping GenAI,
the options and cost considerations
when running these workloads on AWS,
and how FinOps can turn this spend
into measurable business value.
So what will we actually cover today?
JJ will start
with a quick overview of FinOps,
and what we're hearing
from the FinOps community.
Hopefully, that's a few of you here.
Then we'll take a strategic look
at AI trends.
What's happening in the Brocket mar...
What's happening in
the broader marketplace
from technology providers,
and how the GenAI
operating model is evolving
from the point of view of consumers.
From there, we'll review
the main deployment modes for GenAI,
from SaaS APIs through
to fully self-managed infrastructure,
and how those choices impact
both flexibility and your cost control.
We'll follow that with a deep dive
into AWS services and pricing,
so you can see how costs break down
across the build, train,
and run phases.
After that, we'll talk about
key FinOps practices
that you can apply right now
to get better visibility,
better predictability,
and better efficiency
for your AI spend.
And finally, we'll wrap up
with unit economics.
How to measure success with AI,
not by total spend
but by cost per transaction, per user,
whatever matters for you,
so that we can tie investment
directly back to value.
And a quick introduction to FinOps.
- I think a learned audience would know
a lot about FinOps,
but I often meet new colleagues at KPMG
who work in different technology areas.
And the way I describe it is
it's a collective brains trust
of about 65,000 practicing professionals.
And what that gives us collectively,
that brains trust,
is tooling processes, best practices,
that we call as the discipline
of cloud FinOps.
And it does two very
important things for us.
It helps us have the conversation
in the metrics that business,
finance, and technology understand
for themselves,
and with FinOps, for each other.
And the second thing
that it does for us is
it helps us to align our initiatives
and get the best out of
our cloud investments
in terms of maximizing
its business value.
You wanna talk about the foundation?
- Next slide.
Oh, the foundation?
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess, sorry.
Yeah, so the FinOps Foundation,
as you said,
I think about 65,000 people
in that community.
- Yep.
- So I'm gonna guess
a few of you're amongst that group.
Yeah, so it's...
I mean, I encourage everyone
to get involved,
just to Google the FinOps Foundation.
Yeah, their website has
so many good practices,
and recommendations, and videos,
and information about vendors like us.
But yeah, that's sort of the...
The foundation has grown up
to solve these problems
around cloud cost optimization,
cloud cost management,
making sure that we're all maximizing
the value of these investments.
And there's obviously a massive push
within the FinOps Foundation
around AI as well.
White papers around AI.
There's a lot of thought leadership there
to go to.
- Great.
And one of the things
that the foundation does is
to take a pulse
of the community itself.
And these are the results from
the latest survey of 2025.
Midge, does it surprise you to see
where AI and ML spend is?
- Yeah, well, it sort of does.
So I'll just backtrack a little bit.
So obviously, this survey
goes out every year,
so we're getting that feedback
from the community
about what's important to you.
What are your priorities?
What are your challenges?
All kinds of information.
Is Kubernetes an area of concern?
Whatever.
So I believe there's
about 1,000 practitioners
actually respond to this every year.
- Yep.
- So I might actually
just pause for a second.
Has anyone here actually contributed
to the State of FinOps Report?
- Great.
- Yeah, got a few.
So recommend everyone go and check it out.
So data.finops.org is the website.
Every year, it's run.
Obviously, 1,000 practitioners.
You're getting a lot of information
about what's important to the community.
So yeah I was surprised
because looking back
to the prior 12 months,
the FinOps community said
this was amongst...
AI and ML was amongst
the absolute lowest priorities.
And I was quite surprised by that.
Looking forward to the next 12 months,
which is what the slide is here,
you can see that it's actually
now bumped up four places
to the middle-of-the-pack priority.
So I was surprised.
But I think, yeah,
we have some ideas around that.
- I was surprised
but in a very different manner.
I was mostly surprised to see
how everything that's showed up has
just bursted up four or five spots.
That's very unusual.
And now, governance is a higher priority
than waste reduction.
Quickly followed by the idea
of not just looking at cloud,
but beyond cloud,
and getting into unit economics,
and doing so by enabled automation.
So we're talking about a altogether
different scale of prioritization
for the FinOps practitioners.
And when I look at this
more as a forest instead
of the individual trees,
then I think there's a
clear recognition here
that we are now expected
not just to be tactically optimizing
as practitioners all the time,
but gotta take a more
strategic view of things
and align our outcomes
to that business value.
- Yeah.
Perfect.
- So just so we can continue speaking
this candidly with you,
just wanna make sure that
we get the gist of it,
that this is a purely
educational presentation
and we are not here to endorse
any products or services.
And may I request you all
to keep us honest here?
So if you hear anything that sounds
even remotely like endorsement,
I urge you to stop us
and we fix that, all right?
Thank you.
So we talked a couple of times
about taking a strategic view.
How do you do that?
How do you take a strategic view?
So let's talk about
in the context of GenAI.
And a good starting point is
to ask some simple questions
about any technology
to get started with
that strategic outlook.
And I usually think about "why?"
Why are we gonna be using it?
"What?"
What is the economic environment
in which we're gonna be using it?
And "how?"
How are we gonna adopt it?
How much of it are we gonna be using?
So if we ask the same three questions
of GenAI,
my first impression
with GenAI was ChatGPT coming out
about November 2022,
and just the language intelligence
of the whole thing.
You could do emails, summaries,
blogs, content creation
in seconds instead of hours.
Excel formulas, code
reviews, code rewrites,
such wide range of application
towards knowledge work.
So the "why" was very quickly answered
right from the onset in terms of
its very compelling value proposition
of "Why would we look to use it?"
So this almost near vertical graph
of GenAI doesn't surprise me.
In fact, as Midge said,
you'd be hard pressed
to find an organization
that's operating in cloud today
and is not doing something with GenAI.
Would you all agree?
Yeah?
So let's talk about the "what?"
The economic environment in which
this is likely to operate.
The prices at which
this technology is being
offered are plummeting.
Look at the graph in purple
for ChatGPT-4.
Every step down is
on a logarithmic scale.
So within a period of 18 months,
it's come down 100 times.
100 times.
Midge, microeconomics 101,
when prices go down,
what happens to demand?
- I think it normally goes up,
right?
- Yes, right.
Demand goes up.
Price elasticity of demand, right?
So there's this growing expectation.
Already there's so much demand.
Almost every CEO,
we saw that investment,
is willing to put the money out there.
And that's kind of where we are hearing
all the supply side being shored up
by these billions and trillions
of dollars of deal to build
these big data centers and whatnot
to meet that demand.
Some of these deals are so big
that a billion sometimes sounds
like a million.
And add to that
the idea of research being done
by firms like DeepSeek,
using model distillation
and whatever techniques,
and investments happening
all over the world,
not just in US and China,
we can say
that the economic environment suggests
that this technology is very likely
to be available to us
abundantly, reliably, economically
at a global scale.
- Couple thoughts about that, JJ.
So first thought is...
Actually, just go back
for one second.
- Yep.
- So the first thought is
that this is definitely pushing
towards commoditory territory.
This GenAI technology
is being commoditized.
- Yep.
- A little bit like electricity,
which I think we'll talk about
in a moment.
The other thing that comes to mind,
just seeing these charts of these costs
just dropping precipitously,
is Moore's Law being turbocharged.
So we're used to Moore's Law
where the cost of computing power is going
to be dropping by half
about every 18 months to two years.
That's been the case for decades.
And just to see these charts go
like this is incredible.
And so, we're sort of seeing,
instead of being 18 months
to two years,
we're seeing it be more
like two months to three months.
And the compounding effect
of that is just huge.
And so, that's why we're seeing
this sort of...
The cost really dropping--
- Absolutely.
- This commoditization that
you're touching on--
- Yep.
- Hitting.
And so, yeah,
it reminds me of the commoditization
or something like electricity.
- Great.
I think you're in some very elite company
when you compare this to electricity.
Industry stalwarts, like Andrew Ng,
have predicted exactly that,
is that this would be
as transformative as electricity was.
But what that comparison also does is
it gives us a roadmap
to answer the third part, the "how."
How are we gonna adopt to this?
Right?
Leading researchers in this area,
like Dr. Ajay Agrawal and others,
have published a lot of good research
that shows parallels
between electricity and AI.
And they posit that
electricity transformed
the world in three stages,
or you could consider that
at three different scales.
The first, as a point solution,
was quite simple:
Replacing steam.
You took the steam engine out,
you put electrical generator in.
Everything else about your factory remains
exactly the same.
You produce the same output,
you just now have a cheaper, cleaner fuel,
and you've unlocked some value.
As knowledge of using
electricity improved,
tooling start to improve as well.
Lathes, mills, drills started having
these small, small electrical motors.
And so, now, you could fractionalize
your manufacturing by turning
those individual machines on and off.
And that meant you are
now paying for power
only when you were using it.
And that unlocked a little more value.
And then, the architects started to look
at the unique properties
of electricity and realized
that we could transfer power
from one corner of the factory
to another using these
very small cables.
And that gave them
the design flexibility
to start putting machines
in the order of the completion
of the process rather than
their power intensiveness
and consumptiveness.
And that gave us
the single greatest productivity invention
of the 20th century:
The assembly line.
It optimized the whole factory
for the flow.
If we take that analogy towards AI
and see some parallels,
we are already seeing a lot
of use cases that talk
about task substitution.
Clearly, this thing is far better,
cheaper, and faster at some other things
than most humans.
And we're seeing all kinds
of content creation;
first drafts, business writing,
great examples of where we are leveraging
this task substitution type
of value creation with this technology.
Take it a step further,
and we are also looking at areas...
Thanks.
And we are also looking at areas
where we are augmenting human and AI,
with the idea being that
the human expert focuses more
on high value activities
and AI does the leg work.
Good examples would be in medicine.
Diagnostics can be predicted much better
with AI technology now.
And the doctor can focus
on treatment considerations individualized
to each patient,
and thereby you get a better output
and outcome for the patients.
And I know this conference has been
a lot about agentic
and what agents can do
by orchestrating things
between themselves, et cetera, et cetera.
But in the long run,
what may be possible is
possibly anybody's guess
at this point in time.
But one thread that's clear is that
all of that is going to evolve rapidly,
and in ways that may not be
very directly imaginable today.
Just like it was quite unimaginable
to consider that
a whole city would be powered
by one power station.
Electricity made that possible.
But taking this to FinOps,
what are the considerations
for FinOps here?
Right?
From a FinOps standpoint,
what we need to think about is
I gave the example at
three different scales,
point, application, and system,
and your cost
and governance considerations move
very non-linearly at these
three different scales.
And so, when FinOps practices think
about value versus cost,
that's the key thing that
they need to consider,
is what are the cost drivers
and how would they scale?
As they use it scales, right?
So let's look at that next.
Midge, do you drive a car?
- Sorry?
- Do you drive a car?
- I do drive a car.
- Great.
It's got some running expenses,
I suppose?
- It certainly does.
- What would you say is
the topmost running expense
from your perspective?
- I would say it's petrol.
- Petrol?
- Yep.
- Great.
What would be some of
your other running expenses
that come to mind?
- Insurance.
- Yep.
- Registration.
- Tires.
- Yep.
- Servicing.
- I think that's about it.
- Yep.
Okay, great, wonderful.
How about parking?
- Occasionally.
- Occasionally?
- Yes.
- How about infringement?
- Not for a while.
Not for a while.
- That's good.
- Yeah.
Why I was just teasing that out is,
as you see,
when we think about the running cost,
we usually think about
the most consumptive element of it.
But when you look at the scale of things,
there are so many other
contributing factors.
And if you consider
just that example of driving car,
your fuel cost may be worth
like 200 a month,
but once you add all the rest of it up,
it's a sizable amount, yeah?
So let's look at what
the cost drivers for GenAI are,
and just keep that perspective of it.
So what the industry calls
as "inference" is basically
a user, in simple terms,
using an application, sends a prompt,
gets a response back,
you meter that
and you get some kind
of token consumption.
And based on the price of the token,
you get some kind of token cost, right?
But that inference is more like
the tip of the iceberg.
What's underneath that is
to make that happen,
you would still have
all these other costs
in your cloud environments
across production, staging, and dev.
And if you're building
and training your own models,
there'll be even more cost
to get that up and running in cloud.
But that's not all.
How about security, design, observability,
support and maintenance?
How about product management?
How do you get your users
to use it, enablement?
All of these are
very genuine elements
of getting to value,
and many of them may respond
very differently as your solutions scale.
A few slides back, we saw how
the inference cost is coming down
because of the model unit pricing coming
down that much.
Well, what do you think is happening
to some of these other elements?
Do you reckon any of them are going up
instead of coming down?
How about the talent required
to do these activities?
Right?
So there's a lot to think about,
like "Where are our biggest cost risks
"and governance controls would need to be
"to stay on top of this thing?"
- Yeah.
- Right?
So keep these elements in mind
as I talk to you about one
of our success stories with GenAI.
So as Chat-GPT, OpenAI,
came out towards end of 2022, early 2023,
many member firm countries started
to explore this wonderful new technology
that provided so much
potential to innovate.
And they kept going at it
for about a year.
And about March, 2024,
they started comparing
some of their notes.
And they found that, eventually,
they had built something very similar
because the underlying use case was
quite the same.
"How do we get our workforce
"to be more productive?
"How do we get our consulting teams
"to be more productive
"in their engagements?"
And typically, all around
those three examples that I showed,
chat, search, and...
Sorry, the the third one being...
Chat, search, and...
Sorry.
Chat, search.
And I'll just go back and see
what the third one is.
Translation, thank you.
But they also realized that
they were facing some
very common challenges.
Challenges around deployment,
support and maintenance,
release maintenance,
enablement, adoption.
Our surveys indicated that
many of our own people,
as well as the clients,
were a little skeptical
of using AI-generated outputs.
But the key question was,
"Should we continue down
"the individual path track,
"investing time, effort,
"and money in our silos,
"or are there economies of scale
"and scope to be unlocked?"
And the answer to that was
the genesis of what we call
"the KPMG workbench,"
envisaged as a globally available platform
that would enable many, many applications
to leverage GenAI offerings
in a provider-agnostic manner.
And the role that FinOps had to play
in such a global scale is
to be highly strategic
in terms of engaging with
the stakeholders and understand
that once we go to this
global level of scale,
how are we going to invest in this?
How are we going to fund this?
What are the initiatives
that are being taken
to onboard countries,
to bring on developers?
And working with these teams
to understand what timeline
this will scale at.
And how would we then price it?
We often think of chargeback
as a mechanism wherein
we are looking at whatever
it's costing us,
and then finding a fair
and reasonable way
of distributing that onto the users
so that it's cost neutral
to offer for technology teams,
and also so that the user can see
what it's costing and they can make
a judgment on the value.
But when you take a strategic view,
you have to consider,
you don't come up with
a chargeback program
where you're asking
the first passenger to buy the bus.
This thing will scale
at a certain time
to a certain level,
and then only
those unit cost will make sense to apply.
So roll this forward
to where we are today.
Sorry.
And today, KPMG Work Ventures is available
across 100 plus member firm countries.
It's onboarded over 100,000 users,
hundreds of developers,
30 plus applications.
We are about to go live
with 12 modular agents,
hundreds more in development,
enabling multiple teams
across multiple countries
in a globally secure, safe, data governed,
data sovereign environments
to leverage this great technology,
and improve their engagements
both internally as well
as with the clients.
So that's the scale of what's possible,
and we have a long way to go.
We've just started.
It's just been a journey
of about 18 months.
But there's...
As there's so much more to do,
what I would say is,
as Midge talks to you about some
of the deployment options next,
please consider this idea
of what's critical to your organizations
as you leverage this at this scale
that it's potentially possible
to leverage at.
- Awesome.
So strap yourself in,
we're gonna go through
some implementation details,
the trade-offs that
you're gonna look to make,
and then we're gonna dive
into some FinOps practices
that we will apply here.
So...
Yeah, so walking through the three
main ways organizations deploy
Generative AI today,
so SaaS, PaaS, and IaaS.
These are undoubtedly
familiar cloud patterns,
but the trade-offs for GenAI are
extremely important,
so we'll go through those.
So starting on the left,
with SaaS APIs,
these include providers like OpenAI,
Anthropic, and Cohere.
You get instant access
to powerful foundation models
with almost no setup.
You're typically charged per token
or per API call,
so costs scale very cleanly with usage.
A major advantage is the ecosystem
of out-of-the-box tools
these providers offer.
So things like built-in chat interfaces,
coding assistance, productivity apps,
this all comes with it.
But, so...
If sharing data with
a third party isn't a concern
and you don't need deep customization,
this SaaS API is
a very compelling option.
And I know talking from
our own head of AI,
on the Cloudability side,
there are many scenarios we would love
to take this approach
'cause it just comes with all of
these bells and whistles
for free in a sense.
But if sharing your data
with a third party is an issue,
or if you need to do a
lot of customization,
it's just not gonna be possible.
In the middle, we have PaaS.
So PaaS for AWS,
that comprises two services
and we're gonna talk a lot
about those in a moment.
So they are SageMaker...
Amazon SageMaker and Amazon Bedrock.
This gives you more flexibility,
compared to SaaS,
while still offloading
a lot of the operational burden.
You can run pre-trained models,
you can fine tune them,
or you can even build your own.
The good news is that AWS takes care
of the scaling,
the patching, and availability.
You are charged based on usage.
And crucially, you retain control
of your data boundaries.
And a really key point here is
that there are quite a few
very popular GenAI models.
For example, like Claude 4, Amazon Titan.
The only way you can actually run
these models in AWS is
to use Bedrock.
It's the only option
you have available to you.
Finally, IAS on...
IaaS on the right hand side.
This is a self-hosted path
and this centers around EC2, or EKS,
where typically you're gonna run
an open source model
or run your own custom models.
You have full control
over the architecture,
the scaling, optimization,
the data handling.
But of course, with that control comes
all the operational complexity.
Here, you're primarily paying
for the provisioned EC2 instances,
which are usually backed by GPUs.
What you have is maximum flexibility,
but also requires
the most expertise from your side.
So in summary,
each deployment mode reflects
a trade off between control,
customization, and operational complexity.
So now that we've looked
at the three different ways
that GenAI can be deployed,
I wanna ground that
in what we're seeing
from our own customers on AWS.
So let's just start on the left.
This chart shows
the EC2 instance spend breakdown
across our customer base.
What's interesting here is that
about 15% of all EC2 spend is
now on GPU-backed instances.
We can't say that's entirely AI,
some of it will be for HPC
or graphics workloads,
but a large portion of this growth is
directly tied to GenAI adoption.
And for me,
that's a really striking number, 15%.
GPU usage at this scale didn't exist
a couple of years ago.
And it just shows
how quickly GenAI workloads have become
a meaningful slice of our overall AWS
and overall cloud spend.
Now, on the right,
we isolate spend that
we know is associated with AI
and compare GPU-backed instances
to the managed services.
What we see is
the majority of spend today is
actually still on
the self-hosted GPU infrastructure.
Bedrock and SageMaker represent
a smaller but steadily growing share.
And this really does make sense.
Many organizations started
their GenAI journey experimenting,
doing that with open source models
or custom deployments
that they could actually
go ahead and tune.
But we now expect to see
a shift very strongly towards
the managed services because the models
that back those are evolving
from the vendors.
And as organizations mature,
they really care about time to value,
and that's really gonna give them
much better time to value.
So just a little bit of a summary here
of the managed services.
So in terms of managed services,
a quick distinction.
Amazon Bedrock is the serverless way
to run existing models.
It's primarily used
for foundation models,
but it also supports bringing
your own model
through custom model imports.
Amazon SageMaker,
this is the end-to-end
machine learning platform on AWS.
It covers everything
from data preparation to training,
fine tuning, deployment,
and production inference.
Yeah, so just handy visualization to see
where these two services fit together.
So I'm gonna dive into each
of these services.
So starting with Bedrock.
As we just saw,
Bedrock is serverless
so there's no need to provision instances,
and you get really easy access
to really powerful foundation models.
The first workload category
that you see there is the one
that everyone knows best;
Reasoning and text generation.
This is where models like Claude 4
or Llama 3 handle tasks,
like answering questions,
summarizing information,
generating content,
or acting as interactive agents.
So things you're probably
quite familiar with.
Pricing here is based on tokens.
And these are just really
small chunks of text.
The general way people frame this
at about three quarters
of a word is a token.
If you Google more about it,
you'll find out how that breaks down.
But yeah, so you're paying for tokens,
you're paying for what's sent
into the model,
and you're also paying
for what's sent out of the model.
So yeah, your cloud spend really
directly tracks with actual usage.
Another major car...
Another major category is RAG,
"Retrieval augmented generation."
So RAG is all about giving the model
the extra context it needs
to answer questions accurately.
Instead of relying only
on what the model was trained on,
RAG lets you bring
in documents, knowledge bases,
or business-specific information
at query time.
This helps reduce
hallucination and ensures
the model's responses are grounded
in real trusted sources.
It is one of the most common patterns
because it's often the fastest
and most cost effective way
to make a model truly useful
to your business.
So talking from our perspective
on Cloudability,
RAG's really important to what we do.
But of course,
there is these costs
that are associated with it.
All right, so switching over to SageMaker,
AWS's end-to-end machine
learning platform.
Let me walk you through
the typical cost areas
you're going to encounter.
So starting at the top,
the building phase usually runs
on lightweight instances,
like ml.t3s or ml.m5s.
This is where teams prep data,
explore notebooks,
and prototype ideas.
It actually normally is...
Actually, it always is pretty much
the lowest cost phase.
From an infrastructure standpoint,
it's not particularly expensive.
Even though it's where a lot of
the actual hands-on
development process happens.
Next is training,
which is where SageMaker really shines.
So this is where you scale out
on GPU clusters,
typically backed by P4
or P5 instances
for deep learning,
fine tuning foundation models,
or running large
distributed training jobs.
It's also the most expensive
in most ML pipelines,
the half a million dollars
that you said before, JJ,
so visibility and optimization is
really, really important here.
Finally, we get to the third row,
which is inference,
which is all about serving
those models back...
Serving those models back
to consumers in production.
SageMaker gives you a few options here
that you can choose from.
So you can use
regular GPU-backed instances
or you can run on Inferentia 2,
I hope I pronounced that correctly,
which is custom silicon
from AWS purpose built
for high throughput low cost inference.
And if you wanna avoid
managing instances altogether,
SageMaker actually does have
a serverless option as well.
So yeah, generally speaking,
I'm hoping that the pricing structure
here should feel fairly familiar,
given how closely it
actually is tied to EC2.
Now, let's take a look at EC2 itself.
So this is obviously
the fully self-managed option.
As we mentioned earlier,
it's still the backbone
for a lot of GenAI workloads
because it gives teams
complete flexibility
over the environment.
And at a very large scale,
what will tend to happen is
this will actually be
the cheapest option as well.
So just like with SageMaker,
the workflows break down
into the same three phases.
So you've got our building again,
so using lightweight CPU instances,
like T3s or your M5s,
to set up a dev environment,
run your notebooks,
and iterate quickly.
Second, training.
Again, very similar.
Typically on the P instance families
for large scale training
and fine tuning,
where GPU performance really matters.
And then, the final one here is inference.
Traditionally, on the G instances,
with the Nv...
Obviously, Nvidia GPUs,
but increasingly these are shifting
over to Inferentia 2,
which is the chips
from AWS purpose-built for this.
So conceptually,
this really does mirror SageMaker,
even down to the same instance families.
But the point here is that
you're actually really in charge
of the entire stack.
It's a little bit cheaper.
- It's way too many options to consider,
and what you gotta just think about is
"What is your organization's capability
"of handling?"
At the same time,
contrast that with,
"What is the purpose
"to which you're working?
"And do you really need
"that level of flexibility?"
'Cause this can really get very intensive
for your human resource team,
your talented people,
to work out all those details.
So if you're just doing
some minor experimenting type of work,
you may be able to use just
the basic SaaS offering
and test it out first.
But yes, if you truly need
to scale to a solution
to what it needs to be,
and you need all the flexibility,
then there is all those options
certainly available.
- Absolutely.
All right, so as a FinOps person,
this is the more fun part for me.
Our FinOps practices.
So the diagram you had up earlier,
we had the three phases;
Inform, optimize, operate.
- Yeah.
- So of course,
we're gonna start with "Inform,"
that's where it all begins.
Now, I often have...
I often say to people,
"If you're good at cost allocation,
"there's a good chance
"you'll be good at FinOps.
"Good chance.
"If you are bad at cost allocation,
"you will be bad at FinOps."
So it really is
the foundation to everything.
So...
Of course, it's the foundation
to everything AI as well
in terms of FinOps.
So the first place to start are areas
where we can directly map
these cost back to teams.
So some of this AI infrastructure will be
entirely owned by one team
or one business unit,
one group, et cetera.
So we want to have strategies
that we can fully allocate
those costs back to
that team, business unit,
whatever it might be.
And so, the two main things
that we use in AWS,
regardless of really what service it is,
is gonna be accounts and tags.
And you can see some of the details
about those constructs on the slide.
So accounts are the most foolproof way.
You are provisioning resources
in an account,
so we can use that directly
to map cost back in some,
in some cases.
In other cases, you might have
a shared account
where resources are existing together,
in which case tags become
the most useful way
of doing the allocation.
So the good news is that
all of these services
that we just went through,
they do all support tags.
SageMaker, EC2, Bedrock,
they all support tags.
So we need to be working
with our engineers to make sure
that we're using the right team tag,
the right business unit tag,
department tag, so on and so forth.
And then, at the end of it,
we wanna try and use,
ideally, like a mapping engine,
'cause undoubtedly you're gonna have
a mixture of rules,
sometimes you use a tag,
sometimes you use accounts,
use other things as well.
We'll try and use a mapping engine
to officially assign those costs
back to the business
and try and automate a chargeback.
So for this scenario,
ideally, we have all of
our team-owned AI costs,
we're using these strategies
that are automatically getting chargeback.
So that's the first
thing about allocation.
That isn't always the case.
So just like you have databases
that might be shared,
or APIs that might be shared,
for sure you're gonna
have AI infrastructure
that is shared.
And so, you're gonna need to find
a way to allocate that
as cost back to the consumers.
And again, we're gonna use
a very similar strategy
that we would with a database or an API.
And we're gonna try
and use consumption data,
which we would normally refer
to as "telemetry data."
So with a database, for example,
if we're trying...
We've got five different teams using
the one database,
we might use something
like database transactions
to split those costs up.
So if you have 50%
of the database transactions,
you get 50% of the cost.
So how are we gonna do that with AI?
With GenAI?
So the most obvious
telemetry data is gonna be
something like tokens.
So if we have our five consumers
and we can track how many tokens
each of those consumers is using,
we can now split those costs up
and allocate them back as needed.
Yeah, but at the end of the day,
the net result of both of
these types of cost allocation is
that all that cost
allocated back accurately,
we're now able to start holding
our teams accountable.
So yeah, do you have any experiences
that are worth sharing on this topic?
- Well, we've always found
that nobody likes receiving costs.
I would say it's not very different
in the context of AI costs versus
if you're doing chargeback
in other areas of the cloud.
One common thread that comes out is
if you're charging somebody,
they should have some kind
of a lever about their usage,
so they can work on it
and use it more or less off.
The worst outcome,
from their perspective, would be that
they're getting charged for something
but they have little
to no control about it.
So when you choose that telemetry,
as you were talking about,
see that there is some kind of a lever,
some kind of a mechanism,
that user behavior ties it
to that telemetry,
ties it to their--
- Yeah.
- Portioned cost.
So share--
- Yes.
- But with a little care.
Make sure it's accurate.
- Yes.
- Awesome.
All right, so now that we've got
our first phase,
we've got our foundations there,
where we're working
towards being successful at FinOps,
we can now start optimize...
We can start optimizing.
And there's sort of two
parts of optimizing.
One is optimizing usage,
one's optimizing rates.
We'll talk about rates in a second.
So optimizing usage is
really, really specific
to the type of resources
that you're doing...
That you're working with.
So with AI, GenAI,
you do have some quite specific things
that you need to think about.
So I'll just go through these levers
that you have here.
So the first one is to choose
the right foundation models for the job.
No matter what mode you are using,
the three modes we went through earlier,
this is something
you're gonna have to do.
And if you choose the wrong model
that's inefficient for
what you're doing,
you are gonna be inefficient.
So it's the commonality there.
So yeah, look at the model.
Often, you'll see,
there's light models, or mini models,
or domain-specific models.
They're gonna be cheaper,
and often they'll be
more performant as well.
So as a FinOps practitioner,
there's only so much we can do here.
But as our head of AI,
when I asked him, I said,
"Should the FinOps
practitioners be talking
"to the engineering people,
"questioning these kind of things?
"Should we be facilitating
"these conversations as FinOps people?"
His answer is "Yes, yes, yes,"
we need to do that.
The second one here is probably one
that's more familiar.
Rightsizing instances and EKS.
If these things are over-provisioned,
we see cases where the
GPUs aren't even used.
Just make sure you're turning
these things off,
getting the right size.
Caching, just like we can
cache database requests,
we can cache API...
Cache GenAI interactions.
So if there's prompts that are coming in
that are kind of consistent,
we can cache those.
And finally, batching.
And this is actually one that confused me
a little bit initially.
I was like, "Well, how
would batching work?"
'Cause normally, when you batch something,
you batch it up for a while
then you run it overnight.
That's not how this works.
This is kinda like micro-batching,
where it happening really, really quickly
in real time,
and it's just trying to take
a load off the GPUs
by grouping requests together.
So yeah, just some quick things there
for optimizing usage.
Optimizing rates.
Again, so this is the
other side of optimizing.
You commit to ongoing levels of usage.
Amazon gives you significant discounting
as a part of that.
It's great because you don't
really need much engineering effort.
What we just saw a moment ago, you do.
With this, you don't.
I think most people will be familiar
with the EC2 side of this.
The savings plans and reserved instances.
Everything is really moving
towards reserved instances.
We saw an announcement yesterday from AWS,
now they're available for RDS.
Savings plans were available for that.
So everything is really
moving towards that.
And yeah, savings plans are great
because you get the...
You do...
They are more flexible,
they're easier to manage,
and you do end up with
a higher savings rate in a sense
that they sort of gravitate
to the higher saving resources.
In terms of SageMaker,
they have savings plans.
So I would say they're most similar
to compute savings plans for EC2.
And they're similar in a sense
that they will go across regions,
they'll go across instance families.
So if you wanna think
about SageMaker savings plans,
think of compute savings plans.
They work in a very similar way.
One thing that did kind of confuse me
in the past was I wondered
whether compute savings plans would apply
to SageMaker.
They don't is the answer to that one.
Bedrock is the unique one here.
So in terms of making a commitment there,
it's called "Provision throughput."
But it's actually primarily about...
That's primarily about performance.
You're doing it to try
and guarantee that throughput.
And you do get a discount
with it as well.
Those discounts are not published
so it's hard to exactly know
what they are,
but we here they're about 20 to 40%.
But the point is, with Bedrock,
if you are gonna be doing
these commitments like this,
you need to have a really high base load
to make that worthwhile.
All right, so getting to
the last phase of...
So we've done inform,
we've done optimize,
and now we're gonna do operate.
- Great, thank you.
- Gonna finish up in a minute.
- Yep.
This is all about tying back
to the business value
in the operate phase, right?
At KPMG, we have maintained
a repository in SharePoint
around all our AI use cases.
Anything that anybody thought
they could do something
with the UI that will generate value
for the business,
we try and get an entry
into that repository.
And last I checked,
there were like 1,500-1,600 rows
of data in that.
I'm sure some of you would have
something similar in nature, right?
Well, when you look at categorizing
those 1,600 into the scale aspect of it,
it kind of boil down
to those three areas.
So let's look at that unit economics
in that same fashion
of those three different scales.
First is experimenting.
Your teams are looking
to do something with GenAI,
to test out that "Is this thing predicting
"with reliable accuracy
"that I can build some automation
"on top of it
"and create an offering
"that would be worthwhile?"
Right?
I'm sure many of you have this use case,
or use cases similar to that.
And what's key here is
to look at the unit economics lens
in the context of
"What is the cost per such experiment?"
Right?
What is the expected learning
that we're looking to get
and what is that costing?
And that's most relevant to the business.
So we can focus on token costs
or GPU-hour cost.
And for short lived workloads,
that may be just enough, right?
Use some sort of SaaS or PaaS offering
and get to that.
And examples would be you could look
at cost per 1,000
or million tokens,
or cost per fine-tuning run.
We talked about the
second idea, or category,
would be that big productivity boosting,
augmenting type of use case.
And here, you're looking to
obviously boost the team performance
or individual's performance,
and at the same time you wanna have
a control on the costs, right?
And the unit economics lens
then needs to shift to
"What is the cost per that assistance
"that AI is able to provide?"
Or "per that user interaction?"
If it's support triaging
or summarizing of a document,
what is that
individual activity task costing us
by leveraging AI?
And have a baseline from non-AI
to compare it to,
so that you get some sense
of value versus the cost.
That's your productivity uplift.
The third case is
where we are looking
to build something that, previously,
we just couldn't do without AI.
So it's like something
that will differentiate our offering,
something completely net new
as a new feature into a product
or a service.
And I'm sure many of you are building
such wonderful things, right?
And here, you're looking at
that strategic advantage.
So the unit of that advantage would be
something tied either to some kind
of a revenue generating outcome,
or something where the AI feature has
very directly improved the business value.
And a couple of examples there are
if you're looking at it in terms of sales
or marketing leads that are being closed,
or any kind of AI-driven
fraud detection type
of services that basically,
very directly, impacted your top
or bottom line.
Awesome, Midge.
- Oh, we're just about to finish up here.
We've used our full allotment
of time nearly.
All right, so some key resources
to take back with you here.
But some thoughts for you
as you go back next week
to your office.
Back to work.
So what are some things
that you can look to action?
Well, if you are early
as FinOps practitioner on this AI journey,
maybe start at a high level.
Just try and capture
what is your total AI spend
across AWS, across other vendors,
across SaaS, whatever it might be,
just try and capture that total cost.
Try and report that back every week.
Maybe that's something
you could look to do.
If you're further along on that journey,
maybe you've started allocating costs,
but you haven't got your
shared costs done yet,
make sure you're bringing in
that telemetry data.
Make sure that those
shared AI infrastructure
costs can be allocated back.
Maybe you are even past that,
maybe you are...
Maybe you are doing really well
and it comes down to unit economics.
You know, be clear with your teams.
What is that unit metric
that you are tracking to?
Do you have a unit metric?
And work towards that.
So that's what we have for you today.
Thank you for joining us.
We appreciate it.
I think we have a few
minutes of questions.
- Yes, we're happy to take questions.
Thank you.